[Aplausos]
[Música]
a principios de los años 40 en una
milonga del bajo una pareja bailaba
tango con destreza y sensualidad a causa
de la intensidad del baile la mujer de
esta pareja rompió sus medias y tuvo que
retirarse de la milonga avergonzada
un hombre que miraba la escena pensó
entonces medias de mujer que rompibles
se juntó con un amigo en un galpón de
lanús y empezaron a experimentar con
distintas mezclas de gomas líquidas que
juntaron nuevos sobre maniquíes
el 12 de enero
de 1942 la patente 570 35 fue asignada a
las medias de mujer irrompibles la
imagen que está en pantalla tiene poca
resolución pero si pudieran leer el
nombre del inventor no es otro que el
genial
roberto art destacado escritor y
periodista argentino autor entre otros
de los lanzallamas el jorobadito el
juguete rabioso dice los testigos de
época que las medias eran en efecto
irrompibles espero que su grosor era tal
que impedían bailar tango y
prácticamente moverse con naturalidad lo
cual a mi forma de ver no le quita
mérito haberse animado y proponer una
solución
en mi caso el disparador para
inventarnos fue un par de medias fue un
libro fue específicamente la mención
sobre la supuesta existencia de una
máquina para leer rayuela de julio
cortázar
en julio cortázar que escribió rayuela
incorporando un mecanismo innovador por
medio del cual él quería darle al lector
distintas alternativas así como él había
tenido distintas alternativas a la hora
de escribir el libro rayuela puede ser
leída secuencialmente un capítulo detrás
del otro puede ser leída utilizando un
tablero de dirección que indica un
itinerario específico con capítulos
agregados y puede ser leída armando un
recorrido propio por el libro lo cual
justifica la existencia de una máquina
dado que hace falta generar los
capítulos al azar y almacenar los
capítulos ya leídos para no repetirse
me puse investigar y resultó que la
máquina para la rayuela no había sido
inventada lo que sí existían eran estos
planos que el propio julio corta se
recibió por carta donde es posible ver
más que una máquina una especie de
mueble con gavetas donde estarían los
capítulos una suerte de diván del
psicoanalista probablemente el hábitat
natural de este inventor y el detalle
que más me gusta este frigobar después
de todo uno nunca sabe cuánto puede
durar una buena lectura le pregunté a
mis colegas y amigos porque pensaban que
en tanto tiempo nadie había inventado la
máquina para la rayuela y me
respondieron algo bastante obvio la
máquina no había sido inventada porque
dejando de lado las complejidades
tecnológicas era completamente delirante
inventar una máquina que sólo sirviera
para recorrer un libro yo pensé entonces
complicado y delirante para eso el lindo
proyecto para embarcarse a cabo un
paréntesis para explicar un poco mis
procesos de razonamiento esto apenas
como una curiosidad neurológica
el proyecto es muy fácil no me gusta
meterme porque si el proyecto fácil sale
mal uno se siente horrible ahora si el
proyecto es complejo uno siempre le
puede echar la culpa al proyecto para
fabricar el rayo lo matic que reflote
primero algunos conocimientos de mi
infancia nerds yo al igual que mucha
gente de mi generación programada
computadoras de chico porque era la
única forma que teníamos de interactuar
con las computadoras entonces me puse a
investigar un poco sobre electrónica fui
a las casas de 11 y compre una placa
arduino un display o led algunos botones
cables programe el software de esta
máquina y le pedí a un amigo para
diseñar un gabinete a medida donde todas
estas piezas pudieran encajar con
elegancia ya su vez que tuviera la forma
de una rayuela al poco tiempo estuvo
listo el riachuelo matic que es esta
máquina que está acá un objeto un poco
absurdo y simpático que me puso en
contacto con muchos fans de julio
cortázar alrededor del mundo actualmente
está exhibido un prototipo de esta
máquina en el café cortázar en el barrio
de palermo
cuando termine con el rayo lo maté que
estaba un día en el banco esperando para
cobrar un cheque a cabo otro paréntesis
les voy a contar algo de los escritores
no es nada común que esperemos para
cobrar un cheque éste es un día muy
atípico y el banco me da mente estaba
lleno de gente como todos sabrán siempre
hay gente en los bancos en argentina el
horario bancario es muy muy reducido
estaba esperando entonces obviamente no
podía utilizar el celular durante la
espera pensé voy a leer un libro saqué
de la mochila el lector de libros
electrónicos kindle y no llegué al
primer párrafo cuando se acercó el
guardia de seguridad muy voluminoso
obviamente y me dijo que no podía leer
por motivos de seguridad yo tuve ganas
de explicarle que organizar una salidera
bancaria con un kindle es eventualmente
más complicado que trabajar
en cualquier caso no me voy a poner a
discutir guarde el libro me dispuse a
esperar con un tiquete en la mano igual
que treinta y cuarenta personas que
estábamos ahí entonces pensé que tal si
el ticket que todos tenemos en la mano
tiene una historia y no sólo eso qué tal
si esa historia es largo el tiempo que
lleva a leerlo tiene relación con el
tiempo de espera que tenemos en el banco
y le pregunté esto a consulte la idea
con amigos y colegas y ellos me dijeron
bueno la máquina para la rayuela al
final no era tan complicado fue un poco
suerte de principiante pero fabricar una
máquina expendedora de tickets y turnos
es mucho más complejo vas a necesitar
planos vas a necesitar patentes vas a
necesitar permisos de importación una
factoría en china
a esta altura se darán cuenta de que no
me rodeo de la gente más optimista
en cualquier caso tenía sentido lo que
decían pero decidí empezar por lo más
pequeño dije tengo que imprimir tickets
voy a buscar una impresora muy pequeña
que se puede usar para este fin después
cuando tuve la impresora pensé esto lo
tengo que controlar con algo y conseguir
una computadora muy pequeña raspberry pi
que ejecuta el sistema operativo linux
conecte estas dos partes vía las casas
de once a buscar botones un display lcd
de 16 x 2 y desarrolle el software en
idioma de programación python y después
metí todos los componentes en una caja
de fibrofácil a la cual rebane con un
dremel una de las esquinas para que se
pudiera ver mejor
durante la operación le pegó una sticker
y filme un vídeo de esta máquina
imprimiendo un texto en cuento de jorge
luís borges
por algún motivo en este vídeo empezó a
ser compartido y se viralizó de repente
las causas fueron que era una máquina
que tiene una funcionalidad avanzada y
sin embargo se notaba que había sido
fabricada de manera muy casera
este vídeo bueno se viralizó de ahí
llegó a los medios le hicieron una nota
en un medio gráfico de ahí pasó a otros
medios gráficos agencias de noticias
radio y finalmente a la televisión lo
cual me llenó de alegría no por un tema
de ego sino porque me di cuenta de que
los medios tenían ganas de difundir este
tipo de situaciones donde uno crea e
inventa donde no se supone que lo haga
y debo reconocer también que mis
motivaciones para inventarnos siempre
fueron puras en una ocasión un escritor
colega me invitó a la casa y me mostraba
como no perdía tiempo en consultar
información él estaba escribiendo y si
tenía una duda le hacía la pregunta un
asistente personal de amazon entonces
delante mío le preguntó al ex a cuál es
el texto homérico más antiguo y alexa le
otorgaba la respuesta y yo me fui de
allí pensando una cosa no entendíamos
muy bien para qué quería saber cuál era
el texto américo más antiguo si él
escribía recetas de cocina
sin embargo cuando llegue a casa esto me
funcionó también como un disparador y
revolvía en la baulera hasta encontrar
un juguete furbi del año 98
lo desarme con ayuda de una arduino y
otras partes electrónicas le cambié la
personalidad de tal forma que el fútbol
se pusiera hablar como jorge luís borges
lamentó no haber grabado la cara de este
escritor cuando yo lo invite a casa y mi
asistente personal se puso a debatir
sobre literatura inglesa
a este siguieron otros inventos algunos
útiles otros completamente absurdos acá
en pantalla por ejemplo se ve en la
esquina superior un sistema para
detectar las condiciones de conservación
de los libros en las bibliotecas es un
circuito que se coloca dentro un libro y
mide la temperatura humedad para evitar
que los ejemplares se perjudiquen al
lado un teclado que tipear y una y otra
vez la frase de jack torrance en el
resplandor no me tiene que decir ya sé
que es uno de los absurdos
a bajo un sistema para generar poesía en
función a la actividad de las ondas
cerebrales
un recorrido por la arquitectura del
cuento casa tomada para el amazon alexa
una alarma para libros y ese dispositivo
de abajo que se llama book sound el cual
voy a hablar en breve
a la hora de difundir estos proyectos
note que muchas preguntas se repetían y
me decían los registraste se gana plata
con esto me vendería su no estás loco
retóricas o no estas preguntas me
llevaron a pensar que algunas cosas
interesantes pasan cuando uno se anima a
correrse de la óptica binaria entre
actividades que dan plata y por eso
valen importan versus actividades que no
fueron pensadas para dar plata y no
serían dignas de tiempo dedicación ni
atención
está claro que la factura llega ninguno
tiene que trabajar para pagarlas pero
qué clase de personas somos si lo único
que hacemos es participar en la calesita
de las cuentas a pagar qué clase de
personas somos y olvidamos que está en
nosotros desde la infancia la curiosidad
y la intriga por saber cómo funcionan
las cosas que nos rodean para así
proponer nuestras propias visiones
soluciones y artefactos
también es justo reconocer que en el
camino de las invenciones muchas veces
nos frustramos porque no podemos volver
a armar una radio una moto o nos
quemamos con un soldador o aspiramos
emisiones de caucho como roberto art en
el galpón de lanús pero también lo que
pasa es que en este camino de inventar
cambia nuestra perspectiva cambian las
categorías que tenemos disponibles para
asignarle a las cosas que nos rodean y
en definitiva cambiamos nosotros y ese
es el último el mejor invento
me gustaría ahora sí contarles sobre
esta máquina en literatura muchas veces
se habla de la musicalidad de los textos
que yo me puso a pensar que configura
exactamente la musicalidad de un texto
acaso paulo coelho es reggaeton y saer y
borges son jazz música clásica
cómo se podría transformar un texto a
una pieza de música hay manera de mapear
las letras en notas o los fonemas en
notas o se está hablando más bien de una
cuestión rítmica
esta máquina es un intento por responder
esa pregunta y funciona de la siguiente
manera uno abre un libro poco loco una
página debajo del lector se toca el
botón negro la máquina le saca una foto
a la página le aplica un procedimiento
llamado ocr para extraer los caracteres
y después sobre ese texto intenta
generar una pieza de música rítmica
sobre la morfología el largo de las
oraciones la puntuación y a veces hasta
una valoración de las palabras que
reconoce la máquina se toma bastante
tiempo en procesar pero antes de venir
para acá la use con una página de
roberto art el inventor de las medidas y
rompibles ese tema va a empezar a sonar
ahora y me gustaría acompañarlo con esta
guitarra aclarando que esto puede salir
mal muy mal peor que las medias y rompe
inglés muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]
ah
hoy
en cualquier momento empieza
o no
y
[Música]
sí
e
[Música]
y
e
[Música]
d
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]